el río misisipí fluye a una velocidad de
16.000 790 metros cúbicos por segundo
elige la mejor aproximación de la
velocidad a la que fluye el río
mississippi
entonces tenemos dos opciones 2 por 10 a
la 3 metros cúbicos por segundo o 2 por
10 a la cuarta metros cúbicos por
segundo
entonces cuál de estas dos se aproxima
más a la velocidad a la que fluye el río
misisipí estamos hablando de una
diferencia de un factor de 10 ya que 2
por 10 a la cuarta metros cúbicos por
segundo es 10 veces más que 2 por 10 a
la 3 entonces si yo redondeo este número
a la decena de millar más cercana este
número se acerca a 20.000 pero 20 mil es
lo mismo que 2 por 10.000
ahora 10.000 tiene cuatro ceros así que
esto es igual a dos por diez a la cuarta
así que esta sería la respuesta correcta
2 por 10 a la cuarta es igual a 20 mil
es el número que se aproxima más a esto
redondeando lo a la decena de millar más
cercano y 2 por 10 al cubo eso es
simplemente 2000 sería una décima parte
de 20.000 entonces la respuesta correcta
es esta ahora el golfo de méxico tiene
un volumen aproximado de dos mil 434
billones de metros cúbicos elige la
mejor aproximación del volumen del golfo
de méxico tenemos dos opciones 2 por 10
a las 12 metros cúbicos y 2 por 10 a la
15 metros cúbicos cuál de estos dos se
aproxima más a esta cantidad
si yo redondeo esto al millar de billón
más cercano
esto se aproxima
a 2000
millones
que sería este número y un millar de
billón tiene 15 ceros entonces un millar
de billones 10 a la 15 así que dos mil
billones es igual a 2 por 10 a la 15 es
la respuesta correcta y 2 por 10 a 12
eso simplemente 2 billones de hecho eso
no sería ni siquiera una décima parte de
este número entonces el que más se
aproxima es este 2 por 10 a la 15 metros
cúbicos ahora vamos a ver qué dice la
pregunta de abajo dice aproximadamente
cuántos segundos se tardaría el río
misisipí en llenar el volumen del golfo
de méxico
entonces el río misisipí fluye a una
velocidad de 16 mil 790 metros cúbicos
por segundo que es aproximadamente 2 por
10 a la cuarta metros cúbicos por
segundo y el aproximado del volumen del
golfo de méjico es 2 por 10 a la 15
entonces lo que vamos a hacer aquí es
dividir el aproximado del volumen del
golfo de méjico entre la velocidad a la
que fluye el río misisipí para así
encontrar aproximadamente cuántos
segundos se tardaría el río misisipí en
llenar el volumen del golfo de méxico
así que hagamos esto entonces
vamos a dividir 2 por 10 al 15 entre
2 por 10 a la 4a
estamos trabajando con propiedades de
exponentes entonces aquí vamos a dividir
estos 2 2 entre 2 eso es igual a 2 entre
2 por y que hacemos con esto aquí
tenemos la misma base así que los
exponentes los vamos a restar entonces
aquí vamos a poner
10 a la 15
4 los exponentes se restan 15 menos 4 es
igual a 11
por lo tanto esto es igual a 1
x
10 a la 11 lo cual es igual 1 por 10 a
la 11
eso es igual a 1 seguido de 11 ceros
es uno seguido de 11 ceros
y esta sería la respuesta
entonces la respuesta sería 100 millones
aquí está la respuesta correcta entonces
100 millones de segundos son la cantidad
aproximada de segundos que se tardaría
el río misisipí en llenar el volumen del
golfo de méxico y ahí está